we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
I got a voicemail from a guy who he
calls pretty frequently
he seems to think I'm still talking
about Bernie Sanders
now I supported Bernie twice
I believe that Bernie's time has come
and gone
I don't think Bernie's even thinking
about running in 2024 I haven't talked
about Bernie in months but here's a
caller who seems to be under the
impression
that I'm still talking about Bernie
except for the fact that he's an actual
economic and social populist okay so
couple different things here first of
all I've already gone through the math
it's very popular to say Bernie
definitely would have beaten Trump had
he been the nominee in 2016.
um I have not actually seen the evidence
of that I voted for the guy in the
primary in 2016. I have not actually
seen a compelling mathematical case made
for why Bernie would definitely have
defeated Trump in 2016 where Hillary did
not Bernie couldn't even win the primary
well it's because the DNC okay yes to
some degree that's true but I have just
simply not seen the math of that
Donald Trump wasn't Donald Trump
hijacked some of Bernie's economic
talking points you know that
Donald Trump received an inordinate
amount of artificial help otherwise the
American people would have never voted
for a lifelong con man and career
criminal and fast talker and a fully
like Donald Trump part of me it sounds
like this guy is stuck six years ago I
think he's talking more about 2016 than
2020. uh guys I got it we're going to
listen to a little more of this I have
to tell you I don't know why I'm getting
a phone call about this I I haven't
mentioned Bernie even in passing in
months
and it seems like this caller is talking
about a six-year-old election
he
Ard so with that stupid
we know that and that's not unique to
Trump you and I both know that
has Bernie been given uh an honest Level
Playing Field to compete with he would
have easily won the White House we both
know that I I just don't know that be
honest with yourself
from the leadership of the democratic
party that's right and of course the
Republican Party listen there's another
minute and a half to this voicemail I'm
not going to play it
I don't fully understand whether the
issue is this guy thinks I've been
talking about Bernie
or that this guy is still rehashing a
six-year-old election yes we look at
history to understand what what is going
on and to understand the future of
course I understand that
but I just don't really know what's
going on and it's worrying me a little
bit let me know what you think always
always welcome all calls but sometimes
speech has consequences and it might be
me wondering what the hell is going on
we have a great bonus show for you today
um we have been following the World Cup
in Qatar Qatar Qatar everybody has a
different pronunciation okay that's not
what the issue is
uh someone ran onto the field with a
rainbow flag during the match between
Portugal and Uruguay
Uruguay please folks one of my favorite
teams by the way and this of course
relates to a lot of the extreme
right-wing Insanity of Qatar we're going
to talk about it on the bonus show
number two San Francisco is considering
a law that would allow law enforcement
robots to use lethal Force
is that a good idea it's sounding like a
very bad idea we're going to talk about
it and thirdly a Florida woman has sued
Velveeta claiming that its macaroni
takes longer than three and a half
minutes
what does that make any sense what are
the damages well we're going to talk
about all of it and more on today's
bonus Show Ladies and Gentlemen please
get the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad well it makes money to fund the
show and pay salaries and pay health
insurance and do the things that good
employers try to do Alex thank your
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman well that's fine uh I fortunately
I don't have a billion dollar settlement
against me
bonus show join pacman.com
you sign up you get instant access and
again I want to remind you we have a new
free offering it's all funded by the
same membership program we have a and I
believe it's an eight or nine page white
paper
building arguments without Burning
Bridges people call in I can hear them
crying they have tears they say David
I need to talk to my crazy uncle about
his right-wing politics but I don't want
to ruin the relationship
we have a guide for how to talk about
politics with people and how to at least
get them to reconsider their views it is
free it is completely free at
davidpackman.com guide we will see you
on the bonus show and back here tomorrow